hi i'm ria and welcome back to make it
fancy today a friend is challenging me
to take a popular food and make it fancy
let's see what today's challenge aids
hey riya it's kelsey dangerous i love
make it fancy so i'm so excited to be a
part of it this week i would like you to
make
reese's fancy
good luck
reese's one of the most popular candy i
don't crave it every day once in a blue
moon the packaging it's very classic
the milk chocolate is a little bit sweet
peanut butter saltiness balances out me
and kelsey did a cooking mama video game
together i only play mario kart which
character do you play
yoshi donkey kong doesn't drive well
yoshi is the perfect size in the past we
made sweet candies into cakes or at a
dessert i want to try something
different today and i hope it works as
always i'm excited to make it fancy
all right here's what i got thai basil
bell peppers coconut cream baby corn
scallions cilantro garlic dark chocolate
ginger limes and shrimp from the pantry
i got soy sauce fish sauce chili powder
ground ginger red curry paste white
vinegar cocoa powder dried thai chili
pepper roasted peanuts grape seed oil
coconut oil a big pantry today canola
oil peanut butter chicken broth rice
noodle cacao nibs brown sugar coconut
sugar and red curry paste let's get
started
make it fancy
first ingredients this is peanut butter
cups i'm going to spray it in half i'm
just using eddie knife it doesn't need
to be perfect i just want to take off
the chocolate top put this in the fridge
15 minutes later
it's cold and i'm going to separate
chocolate and peanut butter i have to
dissect a lot of things but in real life
i don't do this kind of stuff peanut
butter is also another thing like i want
to know how people start using it like
who first decided grind peanut and make
up peanut butter all right so i
separated the chocolate and peanut
butter and i'm gonna set it aside i have
dried or thai red chili i'm gonna use
gloves because i don't want to bum my
hand take out seeds inside like tap it i
don't have a lot of torrents
for too spicy food
i don't like when it tastes like just
heat i want to taste food seeds it's the
water part if you remove seeds from
pepper it's not that bad i think it's
going to be a nice
kick but it's not too overpowering
reserve this seed for later cover the
pepper with hot water and soak this
about 30 minutes so i have a bell pepper
cut it in half remove stem and seed put
cut side down on a foiled sheet pan
broil this in the oven about five
minutes until the skin is blistered and
black i put it in a heat proof bowl
covered with plastic so the skin got
softened and left there about five
minutes i
because you want to remove the skin even
you're blending something the skin kinda
remains hard okay i removed all skins
and i'm going to put in a blender and
this it's the thai red chili i was
soaking earlier and i'm also going to
put in a blender one and a half cup of
white vinegar blend
strain so it doesn't have a rough bit of
thai chili pepper any seed remaining
right the color is very vibrant and i'm
gonna set this aside i have two teaspoon
of coconut oil half of milk chocolate
from reese's peanut butter cup melt this
together chocolate it's completely
melted two tablespoons of cocoa powder
whisk to combine and once it is
completely mixed add bell pepper and
thai chili vinegar mixture everything is
completely blending together quarter cup
of brown sugar and one teaspoon of salt
cook over medium low until everything is
incorporated it looks nice and a little
bit bubbling and i'm going to set this
aside now i'm going to make chocolate
soy cabbage peanut right let's get fancy
[Music]
now i have chocolate soy covered peanuts
we have many ingredients heat up two
tablespoons of canola oil over medium
heat adding minced garlic and ginger
some scallions cook until fragrant rice
smells good adding red curry paste cook
this until a little bit darker in the
color red pepper and baby corns cook
until softened about 2 minutes 2 cups of
chicken stock bring this to simmer cook
this to six to seven minutes and
meanwhile mix
coconut cream peanut from reese's peanut
butter cup and coconut sugar mix
to combine the curry simmering a little
into the peanut coconut mixture sorry
add this
add some salt taste a little bit
i think i need a little bit salt and
acidity so i'm going to add some lime
juice fish sauce
more fish sauce
it's delicious heat oil over medium high
heat while it's heating i'm going to
season shrimp both
sides i've seen bigger
it's pretty though i love shrimp all
right i'm gonna flip this shrimp is kind
of easy to tell like when it's cooked
because it turns red
i'm cooking whole shrimp shelled on so i
want to make sure everything is crispy
i put down fishing
when i was little not
recently but i want to do it oh i did a
laser clump
digging yeah it's like long shell i
think you will freak out when you google
all right shrimp looks great it's cooked
nicely and crispy everything coming
together i have some rice noodles
covered with boiling water cover this
for five minutes until it is soft all
right so noodle is ready drain water i
hope kelsey will be delighted let's
assemble this is the chocolate soy
covered peanut cut into small pea seeds
doesn't need to be precise size it's
going to be like random shape some
noodle little curry
shrimp i almost forgot i made this hot
sauce garnish with thai basil i'm gonna
also put some cilantro chocolate
peanuts maybe put lime
and we are done
[Music]
reese's peanut butter cup curry spicy
and fancy
nice to see you so good to see you
i usually put you know end products on
the table but i wanted to surprise you
so i'm hiding under the table so close
your eyes oh okay
all right open your eyes
oh
so fancy
right
so please dig in
oh my god
[Music]
wow
really delicious yeah you all cut and
i'll still be here
eating this food
polishing it off kelsey do you want to
guess what his favorite video game is it
a mario game yes is it like the racing
one yes
which character do you normally choose
yoshi me too oh right donkey kong it's
kind of slow to like react i like his
banana peel though you're professional
agree with me same kelsey
did i make wee seeds peanut butter cup
fancy yes you have one last thing to do
do you know is it the handbag yes
this has been my dream
three two one make it fancy
all right i'm gonna take this to go yes
have fun goodbye
[Music]
you